alors florence foresti vous avez déclaré
c'est marrant ouais faire ardisson on
dirait que c'est une consécration je ne
suis pas pressé il faudrait que je me
sente vraiment désiré pour y prendre du
plaisir mais je trouve que y aller pour
y aller forcer les gens à vous recevoir
c'est un truc vous a pas forcément
recevoir pas du tout alors moi d'abord
je t'adore et en plus leur en est fan ce
qui est très rare à laurent c'est vrai
le mieux qu'on m'invite si les fans même
si tu es fan
vous tue on le sait les gens le savent
les gens louent sa
fille adore florence foresti bon
spectacle c'est vrai quand il est
sérieux ça fait peur en plus de
l'émission de laurent ruquier on a tout
essayé ou fait des apparitions
remarquées florence vous avez triomphé
au splendid avec un spectacle intitulé
florence foresti fait des sketches au
splendid et parfois elle amène son chéri
fois la mène son chic voilà ce que je
parle bien français c'est a duré six
mois ça a bien marché ouais
oui c'est entendu ça arrive évidemment
je suis tendu je fais la fille à l'aise
regarde comment faire la passe 1 n'a pas
bien tu attends tu as volé mon soutien
gorge par contre moi tout le monde est
au courant moi tout le monde et de
surgelés le jeu m'a dit laurent baffie a
pris au sérieux
il a piqué vous souvenez quand je devais
pas mettre ça du tout hein pas mon genre
tu veux mon soutien gorge pendant un
mois bon ça
j'avais prévu un petit débardeur blanc
voilà bien coupé bien il a volé mon
soutien-gorge donc j'ai pas pu qui te
dit ça tout le monde le sait les gens
savent tout ce que tu fais tu aurais tu
me laurence te plait je les vends du un
fétichiste il faudra attendre 20 minutes
revient écoutez on affichera voulu
récupérer un peu sale sur wii dont il
est
juste ce serait trop c'est vrai
alors en plus de l'émission de laurent
ruquier fait des apparitions remarquées
florence foresti c'est fut la muse a
déjà dit mais si je reprends à te
reprendre mais dans le bal à quoi en
plus des émissions de laurent ruquier
trois fois alors oui je vois là en plus
des émissions de laurent vité jeu des
comptes est
en plus des émissions de laurent ruquier
on a tout essayé vous fait des
apparitions remarquées l'état laurence
foresti vous avez triomphé au splendid
avec florence foresti fait des sketches
au splendid et des fois elle amène son
chien impeccable
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux